bien dû boire merci madame la présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la garde
des sceaux à laquelle j'associe mon
collègue georges fenech
madame la ministre le fonds de garantie
des victimes des actes de terrorisme et
d'autres des infractions de droit commun
ou fgti a été créé pour indemniser
notamment les victimes d'actes de
terrorisme à la suite de la vague
d'attentats qui a frappé la france en
1986 la loi a prévu d'alimenter ce fonds
de garantie et 75% par une contribution
forfaitaire de 3 euros 30 prélevée sur
chaque contrat d'assurance de biens
souscrit auprès d'une entreprise opérant
en france ce qui est un acquis unique au
monde
sept mois après l'attentât du bardot qui
a fait 24 morts et 45 blessés
les victimes françaises n'ont toujours
pas été indemnisés elle se sent oublié
délaissé par l'état français
c'est une triste réalité vécue notamment
par trois victimes du loiret deux
d'entre elles sont présentes parmi nous
aujourd'hui dans les tribunes elles
m'ont fait part de leur détresse car
depuis le 18 mars date de l'attentât
leur quotidien est de continuer à vivre
avec un arrêt maladie sans complément de
salaire ou fournir régulièrement des
justificatifs
alors que leurs demandes sont de droit
les victimes sont seuls ont seulement
reçu une avance de dix mille euros
octroyés par le fonds de garantie
madame que pensez-vous des trente sept
mille euros proposés au titre du
préjudice affectif pour la perte d'une
mère y at il un véritable débat de fond
au sujet des décisions du conseil
d'administration du fgti composé entre
autres de représentants issus de quatre
ministères différents
que pouvez vous répondre sur le
sentiment de traitement inégal des
victimes du terrorisme en général
pourquoi les barèmes d'indemnisation
selon les préjudices subis sont-ils figé
et enfin pourquoi une clause de
confidentialité est imposé aux victimes
sur le montant final des indemnisations
je vous remercie
merci la parole la parole est à madame
la garde des sceaux
la juge présidente mesdames et messieurs
les députés madame la députée vous
rappelez un événement extrêmement
douloureux et nous avons encore en
mémoire et dans le coeur le souvenir de
nos quatre compatriotes qui ont perdu la
vie dans cet attentat les cinq personnes
blessées les 39 personnes qui ont subi
un choc psychologique et je veux saluer
les victimes dont vous dites qu elles
sont dans les tribunes avec nous dès le
lendemain la cellule de crise et de
soutien du ministère des affaires
étrangères a été mobilisé à rapatrier
immédiatement les personnes qui étaient
qui ne présentait pas de blessures très
graves et les personnes qui ont pu être
ramenés par bateau ont eu un
accompagnement psychologique et ont été
accueillis à marseille par la cellule
d'urgence psychologique
nous avons également mobilisés
immédiatement le réseau des associations
d'aidé aux victimes et le fonds de
garantie a proposé dans l'immédiat une
indemnisation qui s'est élevé à un total
de 585 milles euros et a fait les
premières offres d'indemnisation
nous avons pris en charge veillez à
prendre en charge l'intégralité des
soins et l'onac qui a reçu récemment les
familles qui peuvent être concernés par
le statut de pupille de la nation nous
veillons terme de procédures judiciaires
puisqu'une procédure en tunisie et une
ici à informer régulièrement les
familles je regarderai très précisément
la situation des personnes que vous avez
signalé dans la mesure où les rapports
qui nous sont remontés du fgti qui vous
le savez est placé à la fois sous
l'autorité du ministère des finances et
des affaires sociales et de la justice
les remontées que nous avons sont des
propositions qui ont été faites aux
différentes victimes avec une estimation
de leur indemnisation néanmoins nous
avons constaté qu'il y a lieu sans doute
de revoir un certain nombre de règles de
dans les décisions du fgti et sur la
base du rapport mandel mantel nous avons
décidé effectivement de revoir ses
règles et nous en ferons pas vous
feront par bach dont le plus vite
possible merci la parole est à madame
catherine